when I hear tradition for me because I'm  Nigerian like I think culture that's why  I understand you saying that you know  your dad not being in the house didn't  really affect because that is what this  happens my cousins are the same thing  like it's what if it's if it's what  you're around if it's if that's what  you're socializing to if that's the norm  yeah it's nothing that's it's not on to  you I mean I'm just going to tell you  how it sounds it just sounds like a lot  of excuses to me  like it's just like this is right this  is why this is why this is why because  like like when you're saying oh it's  social media it's the culture it's this  it's that it's that it's like oh that's  that's why I did what I did it's like it  kind of takes away from accountability  when you're just blaming all these  things